[Music]
enjoy yoga please stop you're promoting
white supremacy Srinagar D a professor
of Religious Studies at Michigan State
argued in a recent piece that quote the
explosion of yoga studios yoga video
apps yoga pants' another yoga swag over
the past two decades is evidence you
guessed it of systemic racism built
unquote the labor of black people and
people of the global south
Kathy Roux is the founding publisher of
Catalina magazine more than that she is
our guide to the changing landscape of
2018 and the deepest recesses of the
lunatik left and we're glad to see was
always Kathy so yoga is racist how is
that well according to this article many
white people who do yoga and it's mostly
white people who do yoga so a few of
them understand the culture the history
and the religion behind yoga and they're
simply enjoying it for the physical
aspects of it so they're not truly
understanding yoga and what it goes back
to and they need to if they want to
appreciate it and if not they're simply
giving into this a viewpoint of white
supremacy according to this professor
huh so if if yoga is racist is hot yoga
more racist or less o western yoga is
racist according to this author
according to this professor all Western
yoga so yoga there's practice in India
it has nothing to do with the yoga
that's practiced in the Western world
Pilates are those safe Pilates was not
discussed in the article it's Western
yoga as a whole it's being practiced by
white people white women upper class
middle class people not minorities not
Latinos not immigrants yeah so this is
this is a white sport well that right
there is suspect okay so you know call
the police
what about Taekwondo I mean by these
standards that might be banned right
well I by this author standards perhaps
but she really has a problem with the
yoga in industrial I think it was yoga
industrialization industrial complex
that's what she called it the yoga
industrial complex so show it maybe took
window falls under that if it's wrong
for people
West to practice yoga is it wrong for
people in the rest of the world to use
the internet which was created here part
of our cultural legacy well I think we
understand the culture of the internet
and it doesn't go back to the British
colonizing India and what the Indians
had to do to introduce them to yoga and
show them that their culture was
actually intelligent and that was part
of the yoga movement and that's how it
came to the United States in the 19th
and 20th centuries
so ok yeah so the internet would not the
internet would not what about like
democracy I mean that was invented by
the Greeks in the West basis of Western
civilization no then again no no Yoga
was a way for the Indians to show their
colonizers that they were intelligent
and that they had this wonderful what do
you read your history ok but I just
wonder just interested how many people
who are into yoga in the United States
do you think voted for Donald Trump oh
well the author didn't touch upon that
but what's your gay I mean as someone
who's very familiar with non Trump
voters would you say maybe 1% of people
who practice yoga voted trumpet or is
that you hi according to the author many
middle and upper-class white women
practice yoga so those people who fit
into that category and our Trump
supporters voted for Trump are you
struck by the fact that that series of
descriptors upper middle class white
like that's kind of the whole argument
on the left now so anything that has
those words attached is just bad just
because and anything that doesn't is
superior to that yeah according to this
article those are the people who
practice yoga and do not understand
immigrants and minorities and what
they're going through and perhaps have
more privilege and are able to
experience yoga and other things that
other groups cannot experience so last
question if in a multicultural society
which we live in and I'm for the basic
principle which is they're cool things
with other cultures and you should enjoy
them when did the rules change so we
live in a multi
society but you're not allowed to enjoy
cool things from other cultures or if
you do you have to feel guilty about it
how does that work well the author said
by no means don't stop doing yoga but if
you do it understand that you're only
understanding an eighth of it that
there's so much more to yoga so
understand what people went through to
introduce this to you from their culture
to your culture so have an appreciation
don't just take advantage of it and by
the yoga gear and take advantage of this
wonderful tradition that was brought to
you by another culture interesting I
mean I haven't tested it but I suspect
downward dog is harder to enjoy if
you're hating yourself while you do it
wouldn't you think I don't think anyone
would hate themselves there's just no
more no more about downwards or
self-loathing Cathy is great to see you
as always you really are our Sherpa and
we appreciate it
sorry Sherpa different culture no
offense intended